Let's,
at the Joe Rogan experience.
Some of the more fascinating pieces of evidence in South America have come out
recently about these channels and pathways that they've found in the Amazon that
could not have been created any other way.
But by humans creating irrigation,
humans creating the,
like it appears like grids,
like a city grid,
definitely the Amazon is a colossal mystery and a,
it's one of the subjects that I explore in depth in America before.
First of all,
to give some basic figures,
the Amazon basin is huge.
The Amazon Basin is 7 million square kilometers in area.
Um,
and within it five and a half million square kilometers,
uh,
remains almost entirely unstudied by archeologists.
And that's the five and a half million square kilometers that is still covered
by dense rain forest.
And to put that into perspective,
five and a half million square kilometers is the size of the entire Indian
subcontinent.
So it's like saying we've done world archeology,
but we've just ignored India.
You know,
we've done weld archeology,
but we've just ignored the Amazon is the same as the same Margaret five and a
half million square kilometers.
The view was,
again,
there was a dogma,
there was a preconception,
human beings couldn't have flourished in the Amazon.
It's a,
it's not a resource rich area.
The soils are poor.
Um,
it's a difficult area challenging to get to very far from the Bering straits.
So the view was that humans hadn't entered the Amazon until about a thousand
years ago.
And then gradually,
little by little,
that view has begun to change.
And it's begun to change because of the tragic clearances of the Amazon,
because the Amazon rainforest is literally being cut down and turned into soya
bean farms and a and cattle ranchers.
And in that cutting down process has emerged things that shouldn't be there at
all.
Uh,
for example,
evidence that large cities flourished in the Amazon enormous cities which were
larger than the,
there was a Spanish explorer who went down the Amazon River system in 1541 1542,
he was the first European to cross the entire length of South America from west
to east along the Amazon.
He reported seeing incredible cities,
advanced arts and crafts.
Millions of people are thriving culture.
Uh,
and a hundred years later when other Europeans got into the Amazon,
they couldn't find these cities.
So they said,
oh,
Francisco Oriana,
that was his name,
made it all up.
It was just a,
it was just a fantasy.
And then in the last decade,
as the clearances of the Amazon have proceeded,
we've begun to see the traces of those cities.
What happened was that the Spaniards brought small pox into the Amazon.
Smallpox devastated the local population because there was no immunity to it.
There was a massive die off.
The cities were deserted within a 50 years.
They were completely overgrown by the jungle.
And that's why they were not seen by the explorers who came in a hundred years
later.
But now the youngest being cleared,
those cities are emerging.
And we can say that,
uh,
a city like London had a population of roughly 50,000 in the 16th century.
There were cities of that size all over the Amazon.
Huge numbers of them and a possible total population of the ams.
And that exceeded 20 million people.
Yes,
20 billion.
This is the latest evidence from the Amazon.
And then you ask yourself,
how did they do that?
How did they feed 20 million people in the Amazon?
Because it's a fact.
Rainforest soils are poor.
It's one of the reasons these soya bean farms are really stupid idea because
once you clear the rainforest,
the land is largely unfair tile and you can't grow stuff on it for very long.
So how did they feed all these people?
The answer was they invented a soil and that's how oil has a name.
It's called Tara Prater.
Archeologists refer to it as Amazonian dark earths or Amazonian black earth.
It's a manmade soil.
It's thousands of years old.
It's full of microbes that are not found in adjoining soil.
It's based around bio char.
Uh,
and you can take a handful of 8,000 year old terror operator and you can add it
to barren soil and that soil will instantly become fertile.
It's highly sought after in the Amazon.
And it explains how they fed these people.
There was science in the Amazon,
they create this,
well,
this is something that's not understood.
It's still not understood by soul experts to this day is to how that was done.
But it's one of many intriguing evidences,
pieces of evidence of much higher,
uh,
development in the Amazon that it has been given credit for and have a kind of
Science Indiana.
Jamie's got an image of it up there.
So this is a,
this is Tara.
Yeah.
Wow.
Exactly.
And so was that done by burns?
These controlled burns?
They did.
They,
one way that it was achieved was,
uh,
was to do wet burning,
um,
of middens.
They would be,
they would be burned and smolder they wouldn't burn fiercely,
which just produces charcoal.
They would,
they would burn and smolder.
Um,
and,
and that by what is called bio char would result.
And that's part of the fertility of the soil.
But the mystery is the microbial content of this soil,
which is completely different from the microbes in neighboring soils.
And that remains unexplained.
So do they,
what are the theories?
Composting,
some sort of advanced compost as some sort of some sort of advanced composting.
But again,
what has not been explained is the Ma is the microbial content of these soils.
So they're there,
first of all,
is an issue of how,
uh,
two things,
how large populations get fed in the Amazon and evidence that there was a
culture in the Amazon that was capable of manipulating the environment in such a
way that it could support large populations with the invention of terra prater.
Secondly,
new evidence previously not recognize the Amazon is basically a garden.
The Amazon is a manmade rainforest.
Uh,
there are certain trees like Brazil nut trees or the ice cream bean tree,
which are food crops,
which are very,
very valuable.
And they dominate the,
uh,
the,
the tree regime in,
in the Amazon.
They,
what's,
what's referred to as hyper dominant species.
In other words,
people living in the Amazon over thousands of years selected certain,
which they then cultivated and grew.
So the whole thing is not simply a wild,
pristine rainforest.
It's a very ancient manmade environment and emerging from that man made
environment as well as evidence of large cities,
large populations,
and this mysterious dark earth are huge geometrical structures.
Um,
and again,
I,
I go into this at length in America before because I love this mystery we have
in the UK structures that are called hinges.
Um,
I,
I live in the city of bath and about 30 miles away there's a beautiful site
called Avery and another more famous site called Stonehenge.
And what a Henge is,
is a ditch which has been dug deep and then an embankment has been pushed up
outside the ditch.
When people first saw these structures,
they wondered if they'd been built for defense,
but then it became obvious they hadn't been built for defense.
Because if you want to create a moat,
you put it outside your embankment,
not insight you're embankment.
So an a Henge is an earth work,
which consists of a deep moat with a large embankment outside it that it can be
circular,
it can be square,
and in the UK and other parts of Europe,
it often contains stone circles,
megalithic stone circles as well.
But the hinge itself is entirely in earthwork.
What we find in the Amazon are thousands of hinges that are now beginning to
emerge from the cleared areas of the jungle and others that have been identified
for the first time with Lidar.
Lidar technology is being employed in the Amazon.
It's nondestructive.
You can see what's under the trees.
What does lidar,
light imaging and detective radar,
they bounce laser beams down into the jungle as a whole pattern of them.
You need helicopters and they,
but it doesn't damage the rain forest.
And you can strip away and see what's,
see what's there.
If I'm,
if this is too much about their diversion.
Let me give you the example of Guatemala.
Guatemala is a small country,
if I remember correctly.
It's not much more than a hundred thousand square kilometers in size.
Um,
it is filled with intriguing Mayan ruins.
Everybody has heard of a t Carl.
What archaeologists didn't know was that literally within walking distance of
decal surrounding that whole area where more than 60,000 structures that they
hadn't identified and these have all been identified by lidar in a country
that's just a hundred thousand kilometers in area.
So you have to ask yourself in that five and a half million square kilometers of
the Amazon,
if lidar technology could be applied comprehensively,
what would we find beneath there?
And the evidence already is extremely tempting and extremely tantalizing.
And I'm intrigued by these huge geometrical figures,
uh,
which involve primarily a circles and squares.
And they are classic hinges in the sense that they are deep ditches surrounded
by huge embankments.
They're extremely geometrical.
For example,
you can find an octagon surrounding a square at a place called Jack Ozar in the
Amazon.
You can find a perfectly in closing a circle.
Now that is an exercise called squaring the circle that are archaea are our
academics have given to the Greeks.
They said the Greeks were the first person people who perform that exercise.
But now we find in dated sites in the Amazon that this was being done in the
Amazon long before the Greeks.
What are the dates at?
The earliest dates that have been found in these sites now are about three and a
half thousand years old,
about three and a half thousand years old.
But the evidence is that the sites have been constantly remade and what
intrigues me is what remains in that five and a half million square kilometers
that has not been investigated yet.
We are just,
I think looking at the edges of a mystery,
the archeologists involved to a mainly from Finland and also from Brazil feel
the same.
They're,
their estimate is that there are thousands of these structures remaining in the
jungle and they're open as to how old they may ultimately prove to be.
The investigation needs to be done.
But what's fascinating about them is this very powerful geometry and astronomy.
So a number of the sites are perfectly aligned to true north,
true south,
true east and true West.
I'm not talking about magnetic north,
I'm talking about true,
astronomical north to do that.
There's only one way to do it.
And that's with,
uh,
with astronomy.
So that tells us that astronomers were at work in the Amazon.
The geometry is very complex and very precise.
That tells us that people with geometrical skills,
we're working the Amazon.
And thirdly,
the scale of the sites of hundreds of meters,
gigantic earthworks on the scale of hundreds of meters,
uh,
tells us that this was highly organized.
A project that was undertaken on a very large scale or very large number of
people.
It's a wonderful mystery and,
and deserves much further,
much further attention.
And I'm,
I'm,
yeah,
that's Giacosa exactly.
The square squaring the circle.
So you can see the outside embankment and then inside it is the square ditch.
And then there's another embankment inside that and a circle and a circle inside
that made a road right through the [inaudible] road.
Yeah.
You know,
because,
because there's no respect for,
there's no respect for the ancient,
for the ancient world,
unfortunately.
And there's another one look at that.
Wow,
that's incredible.
That thousands of the sound,
the stuff that they found in the Amazon,
what imaging technology where they're using to find all.
Initially,
initially it was entirely found because areas of the rainforest had been
cleared.
Economic interests said,
we want to make a cattle ranch here,
or we want to make a soy bean farm here.
So we're just gonna clear the rainforest.
In the process of clearing the forest,
they start discovering these earthworks that had previously been completely
overgrown by the jungle.
Then the next step was to say,
uh,
what can we,
what can we do to find out more about this?
Obviously they don't want to destroy more jungle.
And Luckily we have a technology which is,
which is Lidar,
as I mentioned,
which uses radar and using lidar.
They've been identified,
able to identify many more of these sites and then to get to the sites without
destroying the jungle and to begin excavations on them and to find that they go
back in the cases of the ones that had been explored so far,
at least 3000 years.
Uh,
this is an intriguing development,
completely unexplained in our understanding of the Amazon.
And what it suggests is a heritage of extremely ancient knowledge.
You don't wake up one morning and,
you know,
create a perfectly geometrical square or circular earthwork that's perfectly
aligned to true north,
south,
east,
and West on an enormous scale.
There has to be a background to that.
That'd be a reason for doing it.
And the evidence is none of these sites were lived in.
There's no habitation,
a refuse founded in them whatsoever.
They were,
they,
we don't know what they were used for.
I make the case,
uh,
in America before that they're connected to a system of ideas,
which is found all around the world,
which,
which is to do with death and the afterlife,
destiny of the soul.